المسيرات الرخيصه سلاح ايران المفضل
ارسلتها طهران الى كل مكان حيث ميليشياتها
في سوريا والعراق واليمن ولعب دورا في حرب
الوكاله لتعظيم الموقف وتهديد الممرات
المائيه لتنفيذ مشروعا الخاص
المسيرات الانتحاريه التي تجمعها ايران
تستخدمها كورقه ضغط لتحقيق مكاسب في
المفاوضات النوويه او لرفع العقوبات
[موسيقى]
لطالما كان الغرب يفكر باليه للحد من سلوك
ايران ومسيراتها وما حدث في اصفهان كان
رساله لتغيير في الاستراتيجيه
مسيرات من داخل البلاد تضرب موقعا عسكريا
هذه المره في ايران وجود خلايا واختراق
داخل ايران مساله تتصاعد حيث كان البرنامج
النووي الايراني هدفا لمحاولات تخريب
متكرره في عام 2020 اغتيل كبير العلماء في
البلاد وتعرضت منشاه طنز النوويه لاضرار
الجزئيه وفي العام نفسه تم ضرب منشات
الكراج
مسيرات اصفهان ضربت مصنع اسلحه حكوميه
ايرانيه في وسط مدينه اصفهان والذي تصادف
ايضا ان يكون مركزا لانتاج مسيرات يقال
انها ترسل الى القوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا
تصريحات اوكرانيا لطهران بعد الهجوم باننا
حذرناكم ورد روسيا العنيف الادانه الهجوم
كلها اسباب تؤكد هذا التوجه وقبلها تحدث
اعلام امريكي عن ان اسرائيل هي من نفذت
الهجوم ومهما يكن من امر فانه هجوم اصفهان
يشكل نقطه تحول في المواجهه بين الغرب
وطيران بنقل المواجهه الى داخل ايران
نفسها التي تواجه احتجاجات ضد النظام الذي
فقد الحاضنه الشعبيه له